hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach alright so I recently updated the
game to version 3 J point version 0.3
point tube so I lost my same things
again
so X X X X X mark
pown X X X 7 disabled and let's get into
this oh I'm already regretting it I
gotta go through it all again but it
should have fixed some bugs that whole
elevator situation when the other one
was a bug and not intended like this
game is supposedly not supposed to get
me stuck and I am smoking
that's awesome man
so happy about that another one please
ah ow I'm up throw it those now what
does this is in front kind of widen the
walkways here let's see
link oh no oh no what is that what what
was that
who's this
I'll fix safe I don't have a key card oh
we can okay okay we're okay that was
nothing is this a joke haha that's so
funny
hahaha thank save oh I know that sound
oh that one was off huh he's moving
around oh one of these as long as he's
not in here with me I'm perfectly okay
with that would I get
1:06 I think I've read 107 oh whoa what
is that I have not read this ICP 106 is
old milk physical interaction with
scp-106 is allowed at any time all
physical interaction must be avoided by
no less than two-thirds full of from o5
command in corrosion oh man
elderly humanoid appearance of a chance
decomposition not agile and will remain
motionless can pass through solid matter
that's ah that's a bad thing that's a
bad thing
yes it's very bad okay ah the navigator
and I'm still to stick this and that BAM
cool oh yes couldn't connect to the
database so battery is good though
battery's good but it can kinda okay
it's kinda okay it's okay
what huh
say again whatever the hell that was
okay I got a key card level two key card
let me try going back notification
please refer to all CSCP level items by
their case designate review numbers
while common reference main names are
more convenient it is both misleading in
a senior junior expose me leading an in
professional case in point anywhere
computer reference to radical area in
scp-106 reports will be met with
disciplinary review from sector
supervise ok let's try going back I
wanna see there's anything in that still
off
okay that's off okay okay okay so far so
good so good so far so good okay I need
a key card
big minute boopity boop boop boop boop
he's gonna this is the thing I read
about this I read this one oh oh ooh ooh
this is the SCP that um can transmogrify
trends morgue if I yes it can
transmogrify wait hold on ah I can put
like uh I read something I think I can
put this in here her a on I think I can
I can
how do I do this I don't know how to's
boy buddy I can like put things in here
and it'll turn them into super things
whoa that's fancy yeah that's like a
yeah this thing is exceptionally
interesting I'm here if there's a file
on it
let me just close this door please hey
whoa no oh that's how I drop it okay I
just got drop it in here ha okay let's
try that and go drink it all
and it turned into a keycard omni hahaha
yes alright and here's why all oh this
isn't it no organic manner is to be
entered into scp-914 at any time please
false standard review procedures in
regards to input both checklists to
prevent any and all accidents we do not
wish a repeat of the spider steel wire
incident of last week okay that didn't
explain what scp-173 was but basically
it's a machine that's um it has a bunch
of different settings you can put things
in it and it will crank out various
things I don't know how many
combinations this possibly has let me
try putting my uh my gas mask in and I
don't know what I put that in there
crank it out at very fine
by something very horrible
guard omni
actually no let me keep that over space
I mean run out of here and that turned
it into a gas mask okay let me try the
navigator cuz I'm just uh I'm not sure
if I might need something to happen in
that regard all right Frankie Frankie
and so weird like
on the bus I'd never had a moment's for
free whenever I play this game and OS
not have navigator ultimate oh yes oh no
no no you go you go away you go away man
you go away scp-173 okay I got my I'm
gonna keep this safe I got I'm doing
good looks like the most progress I've
ever made I got my key card Omni I got a
super navigator my gas masks didn't
change but whatever this is good so good
oh man I don't want to lose this safe
let's go now I can get in anywhere I get
in any door no matter what
what was that good
I've read this before this guy oh I've
already been here okay
we drop this we drop these um stuff I
don't need iron you know about that I
read is known okay I don't think there's
anything useful in here is where that
thingy that I read about before is was
sentient object fantastic that's so
great for it good not bad stop that stop
that stop it
golly this again Oh eyes it laughs what
is this what is this what is this what
is this what was that what's that
like you use this I can do this yeah
okay what's here
okay card okay let's close this up cuz I
don't want no maybe that's a bad idea I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what are these some SCP for 20 minute
wait a minute
hahahaha and eff them good a [ __ ] man
low five key card too bad I don't need
that anymore nuclear device oh oh the
Alpha warheads for 100 mega warhead five
done okay this is designing in case of
containment breach and maybe I need to
keep that one but this one yeah that one
can go so um let's go yeah and I don't
think I need this key card bummer hold
on to it just in case with this radio
prefer one two five
I need a battery and I just pick up a
damn it I know that's what I needed
no what's an email print what wait hang
on
oh hang on have we gotten a confirmed
timetable on when this dam overload will
be over yet all I get from central is
the same emergency notice even with the
extra staff we're having more than an
acceptable amount of incidents if
something goes wrong with all that we're
holding right now we might have to lock
down the whole site please make every
effort to keep any and all staff in
designated work areas during the class
transfer periods we are aware this is a
stressful time but we all must do our
board game things running in as smooth a
fashion as possible uh missing security
cam footage to confirm casual skinner
missing zero seven nine s door what was
that what was that what was that okay
anyway man
Oh
okay what is that what oh yeah that's me
name redacted my name ain't redacted
your radec okay
got the email maybe I'll need that but I
don't need law maybe on these I don't
know what I don't do and do not need
alright moving forward I am very very
concerned that I have not seen one seven
three yet oh not this I hate this I hate
this part
is he in there please tell me he's not
in there I don't want him to be in there
I want him to not be there alright let's
just get through here OOP Brent Brent
Brent Brent he's out there he's out
there he's Arthur he's not sure I hear
him where is he where is he where is he
where is he where is he for the query
the query
so weird
Oh what is this I know this is so
freaking me out that I have not seen him
yet it is like beyond unknown we is
weird I know he's gonna pop up around
jump around a corner and cure the bit
easy that we don't see any items
security clearance doubles I don't need
that that's unnecessary information
what was that don't be don't be object
classes I already know if you want to
find out more about SCP just Google SCP
foundation and there's tons of stories
about you know what this Oh Oh a door
opened where where where where where
where where where where where where
where where I don't know I don't know
what's up here I don't know I don't know
why am I asking questions on that no one
can sir anyway I'm actually all out of
time so oh thank you pause it's green
uh-huh
I'm safe with you right okay all right
so I'm all out of time thank you guys so
much for watching click the annotations
it's see more stuff that I've done
check out my Sunday reaction compilation
right down there ah
and thank you so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye